mississippi orland declared because it was the start of the 18th century before they had got that
far in the south the comanches were fighting a bloody war against the spanish invaders out here
in the east skirmishes with the new arrivals and massacres went on pushing the indians toward the
west and that's what happened to the blackfoot tribe and the cheyenne and the sioux and many
others until on these vast plains no white men no horses no firearms like this for long we're
We're marching to the rivers where we can hunt buffalo.
And will you let me hunt with you?
You're too small now, later when you're grown up.
Possessions, go to your mom.
Which animals they're riding?
No, never saw them before.
Seems to be a friend of man, so it must be a dog.
It's a big dog, it's good to eat.
I wouldn't be surprised.
Good meat, you can tell, touch it.
It's not a buffalo.
Didn't do too badly, did we?
Guess not, they didn't steal much, and we got good meat.
Thinking, with these big dogs, if we had some, it would change quite a lot, eh?
Hmm, yes.
Signal means danger.
Think we're going to attack them.
In fact, we come as friends, and it would be a lot better to tell them.
It's all right.
Coming, guys, we can go to see them.
See you the same color.
That's it. We are friendly Indians.
These ceremonial positions, I'm getting too old.
Badly loaded my peace pipe.
Now how can we have a decent powwow with a pipe like this?
Why didn't you tell me there was no tobacco over my pipe?
It's a real calumet.
We were attacked by Apaches.
They were on ponies.
It was a ferocious attack.
That makes you angry, eh?
Well, that's what it did to us.
Now, let's talk business, all right?
Buffalos.
Have you seen any buffalos around?
West, north, south?
No, well, would you like to trade a little?
You're an Indian, and don't you forget I won't trade.
I'm keeping that one.
Wrap it up.
I'll take it home.
Buffalo.
Good news, it's lots of them.
Remember, when you hunt, it's not for your own glory to be above the other.
When you hunt your belly together, little chief, as it happens, I am that chief.
And if you don't obey, you'll be, he said it.
I want you to kill the number we need, no more.
Remember that every one of you, be what we need.
In a word, every big dog will be sitting pretty.
Here, children, over here.
Now, I'm going to show you something that's going to surprise you.
You remember those eagles that you caught?
Well, when you're warriors, you learn the right to wear certain feathers.
Now, if you strike an enemy, or if you are wounded, once or several times,
Another one if you kill an enemy, and especially one if you scalped one.
Yes, but we're already grown up, and they won't let us be warriors.
That's right. They won't even let us hunt with them.
And we're good hunters.
Now, now, patience, little ones.
You have to learn patience, and you'll become hunters pretty soon.
But first, you must submit to certain trials, fasting, sweating, to purify your body and your mind.
No, you go in search of the great mysterious spirit first and all the power that will help you.
The eyes of the heart seek sacred contact with you.
To generations, heed their all greater glory.
A very good sign.
You will be a great hunter.
There was a giant eagle protecting me, Mr. Hunter, my lad.
What I saw was a big snake.
I mean it.
It was easily this big.
In that case, fair play isn't going to be in your makeup.
In yours, tell me.
Snake, too, but a small one I saw.
Yeah, a tiny little one.
It was about this big.
Wasn't a great big one.
A little one like that.
Oh, right.
Tonight, you will come to my teepee and I will give you your protective charms.
There, now, each of you has his medicine charm, pebbles and healing herbs.
And you will get your feathers after you have earned them.
I'd like to know what's in your medicine bag.
My lad, I am the shaman and big chief, I am a healer, I am an astrologist and more.
Naturally, if I'm going to do all this, I need the tools of my trades to predict and cure and visit the spirits.
Now, all of you are men. Go out and dance with the other warriors.
I was absolutely sure the big dogs were going to return.
They, uh, trade things.
But why not in all your goods?
But I am interested in your big dog special.
Nobody right makes you ask me.
I just wondered because, well, I think you're beautiful.
You like to be my squad, huh?
Do you have any of those big dogs?
Ponies, we call them.
Why, no, as it happens, I haven't got any.
But I'm going to get some.
Huh?
Now, our big dogs are ponies.
There are three, but the hunting season's approaching,
and for that, we'll need more of them.
Many more if we're to travel.
Now, in the village, it is said that the Poncas have ponies.
Four moons march from here.
This can serve as an excellent trial for our young braves.
Near their mountain expedition, bringing ponies back.
Set off on a buffalo.
Hide well, or they're all strong.
So, son, study them well.
If the one you've chosen runs straight,
you can go up close to him and kill him with your arrows.
Turns his head, looks at you from the corner of his eye.
Careful, he can turn on you, rip open your pony and kill you.
At last, ponies, wild ones, and I knew that one day we'd find them.
I knew that one day the great powers would send us ponies.
Now prove your men, braves, all of you. Come, friend.
Together we will capture the ponies for the glory of our tribe.
I will give you the finest eagle feather and the softest sap.
And the buffaloes are rare ponies, so now we can move much more easily.
In my opinion, we must migrate before winter.
What is this? Your face is pale. Are you sick or what?
Well, let's begin or else we'll never get started.
Rifles, whiskey, germs brought by the white man,
gifts to the Indians of the Great Plains, yes.
Yes, all this was to change their way of life.
The unstoppable steamroller, the white man's advance,
would soon chase the Indians from their lands.
Farther, always farther.